where's this
Prometheus is trying to beat me I don't
want to put the recruits in harm's way
until we know exactly what it is we're
doing these killings are some kind of
message that Prometheus is sending to
Oliver you've got a to kill list
Prometheus is saying you're the serial
killer hey youtubers is Charlie so new
arrow this is gonna be a video for the
Prometheus trailer as well as episode 5
the human target episode and Talia al
Ghul and Katie Cassidy coming back in
episode 10 so a whole bunch of stuff so
just addressing this footage real quick
there's a couple things that are
happening between episode 5 the human
target episode in the next episode is
basically a transition from Tobias
Church sort of like the small bat of the
season like the brother blood to the
death stroke you know Prometheus Big Bad
of the season so they're wasting no time
that's why the name of the next episode
is so it begins which has a lot of
echoes for season 1 stuff like when
Oliver first came back to town like so
begins my mission the team looks like it
learns about Oliver's list we haven't
seen that in a couple seasons so it
looks like Artemis is thumbing through
here we don't really know where this
falls in the timeline but we do see
Artemis versus Prometheus by herself so
Prometheus is just going after Oliver in
earnest now and if it wasn't clear from
episode 5 from the human target episode
that is definitely Worf doing the voice
for Prometheus now that doesn't mean
that he's underneath the mask it's just
like a dr. alchemy you zoom thing where
you have like a really notable actor
with a really identifiable voice like a
really cool scary voice doing the voice
so that they can put whoever they want
underneath the mask they don't have to
reveal that right away or even
necessarily cast that character but the
whole thing here is that Prometheus is
taking issue with things that Oliver did
they go back to season 1 mistakes he
made they kind of teed that up in the
human target episode when they talked
about Queen consolidated
misappropriating land that was supposed
to go to the people like Oliver has this
Zoning project that he wants to benefit
low-income families and people of the
city that they're trying to redevelop
areas of the city you
or how the glades is basically like a
complete [ __ ] area so this new area
which is like different that they're
trying to develop might be similar to
that they're basically just trying to
turn it into a nice place for people to
go live and benefit from but the other
councilmen that Oliver had to convince
to vote in favor with him was like well
your family you know 25 years ago we
totally tried to do this but your family
took land for its own benefit that's
where the Queen consolidated building is
but then they flip it around on him and
say you know you're calling us out for
doing something that was kind of shady
but you're super shady yourself and then
separately you know kind of shady person
Susan Williams is trying to find out
what's going on with Oliver doesn't
think he's qualified thinks that his
heart is in the right place but he's
totally unqualified and it's gonna end
in disaster
but you know obviously they have the big
twist with human target where Oliver
makes the bargain with her give me
months to prove myself and I'll turn
things around like you will like me by
the end of this month and think that I'm
a good mayor she's still trying to out
Oliver Queen but I don't think she has
any motives beyond just getting a really
big story I don't think she's like super
evil or anything like that I think she's
just an [ __ ] reporter that's gonna
get tied up with Green Arrow stuff
because she's slowly learning about
Oliver's time off of the island but the
important stuff you know thematically
the idea that even though Oliver's heart
was in the right place he was making
some big mistakes in that will probably
have something to do with why Prometheus
is going after him and that will also
tie into the list as we see in the
trailer so whoever prometheus is he has
major beef with Oliver from something
that Oliver did like the kill list that
he had in season one like they talked
about it rag man says Prometheus is
calling you the serial killer
so either Prometheus as parents were
someone on Oliver's kill list that
Oliver killed or he's connected to them
but there's always a big twist like you
know Prometheus is calling Oliver out
for being a murderer which is not wrong
but the problem with that is that the
people on Oliver's list were all
terrible people that deserve to die so
that's where you reach the impasse so
like the Prometheus character is out for
vengeance and is you know may be
justified like you
killed my father prepared to die but is
also doing a lot of terrible things in
their pursuit of justice so like a lot
of stuff that Oliver has done has been
technically wrong even though it's been
for the right reasons so this is just
his past coming back to haunt him but it
does throw a little water on the Tommy
Prometheus theory because it would be an
awesome twist if his friend came back
and were coming after him but there's
still like a short list of people that
it could be everyone's been referring to
Prometheus with a male pronoun so I
think they want us to assume that it's a
man but the producers haven't really
said anything about flashpoint
influencing who this is there are a
number of reasons to explain how it
could be Tommy but it could also be any
number of people as long as you narrow
your search to people that are tied to
the list so you're really talking about
the crime families in the city so
whoever prometheus comes from they're
terrible people in their own right the
human target stuff so there was a lot of
like funny moments in this episode too
it wasn't all plot there was a lot of
plot development which was exciting
because they're like finally pushing
forward but the way they describe human
targets abilities is pretty accurate too
the comics the Christopher chance
version that they used in this episode
is the second version of the character
he showed up for the first time in a
Superman comic the first version of the
character showed up like way back in the
1950s in Detective Comics so he doesn't
have any metahuman powers it's all just
sleight of hand and a really good
ability to become other people like act
as other people would act so it was
funny to see him show up in the
flashbacks at the end of the episode
that was a funny twist like Oliver
totally didn't recognize him in present
day which should give you an idea for
what Oliver's mind state was like back
then but it was a nice special effect
with the mask when he ripped it off and
then you know Felicity was playing with
it you have failed this city that was
probably the funniest Felicity moment in
the last couple of episodes but let me
know in the comments what did you think
about episode 5 the human target episode
and what do you think about what's going
on with prometheus do you think that
he's Tommy do you think that he's
someone else I want to believe that he
could be Tommy
but I'm not a hundred percent on it I
feel like flashpoint won't be
responsible for who prometheus is and
unless Merlyn
use the Lazarus Pit without telling the
team that that would be a really big
leap to make then it's not Tommy
so the other big thing is that they've
also said that katie cassidy is coming
back to the show in the way they talked
about it makes it sound like it's a
permanent thing like she'll be coming
back but there'll be some giant twist in
it's episode 10 so that's like
completely up in the air because it
involves like a bunch of leaps and logic
like does Sarah save her on legends of
tomorrow is that a version of her from a
different earth there are so many
questions so we'll probably have to wait
a couple more episodes it's a little
early to speculate on which version of
Laurel will be coming back to the show
and the other thing you probably heard
about is Talia al Ghul also coming to
the show in episode 10 so we're getting
Talia al Ghul and black Canary or at
least katie cassidy back in episode 10
so maybe you can make a connection
between those two things maybe there's
some molasses pit secret Lazarus Pit
stuff happening but because of who Talia
is even if they're not doing a comic
book plot I do think it will be League
of Assassins related Nyssa dissolved the
league last year so Talia might be
reforming it in some way but they'll
have like a nice sisterly rivalry when
they bring them on the show together
eventually it'll be nice and crazy the
way it should be because there was a
period where Nyssa was torturing Talia
by killing her and throwing her in the
lazarus pit to resurrect her over and
over and over just to drive her insane
so we'll see what she's doing whenever
she comes on the show they haven't said
much about her but I am excited it'll be
a lot of fun but as far as I know there
is a new episode of arrow next week the
flash is on break-in agents of shield
what you know normally Tuesday night's
show is on break for a couple weeks so
even though there's an election in the
United States and it's disrupting a
little bit of Tuesday TV it seems like
Wednesday will be normal so I'll do an
arrow video next week for those that are
asking yeah totally keep doing arrow
episode videos this week was just a
little weird because we had the World
Series last night that pushed like super
late into the evening and we had Wonder
Woman this morning but yet height the
next couple of episodes are actually
really big on arrow flesh
pretty much all the DC shows obviously
agents of shield has ghostwriter stuff
going on - there's a lot of big TV stuff
happening because we're building towards
the mid-season finale on pretty much
every TV show so next video will be my
spoilery Doctor Strange review but there
is a DC giveaway that's still going on
right now that'll stay open until I post
my legends of tomorrow video which would
be sometime tomorrow or maybe Saturday
morning depending on how fast I can get
all my Doctor Strange stuff out so get a
whole bunch of comic book stuff
happening this week will you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
like the next big flash trailer and you
can click here for that flash episode
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight